c'est en présence des officiels que la
présidente du département pose la
première pierre du futur centre
d'incendié et de secours de saint-andré
une nouvelle caserne qui s'inscrit dans
le schéma de développement et
d'équipement du service départemental d
incendie et de secours de la réunion on
leur apporte également l'aide financière
du département 52 millions d'euros pour
le budget de cette année et 120 millions
d'euros pour la construction des
casernes
on réhabilite des casernes on en
construit de nouvelles il y a plusieurs
projets aujourd'hui en cours sur la
commune de saint paul sur la commune du
tampon de saint benoît la pose de la
première pierre
ici ce matin à saint-andré également là
sur la commune du port
il y a de saint paul il y a donc des
projets qui avancent et qui sont portés
par les communes est également le
conseil départemental
le centre d'incendié et de secours de
saint-andré réalise près de trois mille
interventions chaque année avec ses
nouveaux bâtiments
les pompiers disposeront de locaux
administratifs des espaces de vie d'une
zone d' alerte d'une zone technique et
des espaces extérieurs
cette construction nous permettra donc
de choses évidemment d'améliorer la
qualité des secours sont va gagner en
rapidité d'intervention c'est un
programme fonctionnel du début en fait
de la réception de la lettre à la
transmission la larme pour les
personnels donc un schéma circulatoire à
ces facilités donc ça ce sera pour
améliorer la qualité des secours sont à
gagner en rapidité d'intervention
et puis deuxièmement en termes de
qualité
d'installation pour les personnels qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas des locaux qui
sont très très adapté puisqu'il remonte
aux années 1970 où leurs activités
étaient moindres ou leurs sollicitations
était moins évidemment
alors que là ils disposeront à l'avenir
de locaux fonctionnels donc avec une
qualité d'habitat et de fonctionnalités
grandement améliorée treize sapeurs
pompiers assureront une garde permanente
sur ce site un site stratégique qui est
le troisième pôle d'intervention en
matière d'activités opérationnelles à la
réunion notre ville va enfin être doté
d'un centre d'intervention qui va nous
faire gagner du temps et en matière de
sauvetage des vies humaines
le temps c'est de la vie en matière d'
incendies le temps c'est la protection
des biens matériels est situé
stratégiquement entre le chez h&r le chu
et le centre de soins critiques
j'espère que cette caserne va être un
outil qui va faire nous permettre de
sauver des vies humaines
financé à hauteur de 80 % par le
département et de 20 % par la commune de
saint-andré la future caserne sera livré
en avril 2010 est la spl à venir réunion
mandataire pour le département sur cette
opération assure la maîtrise d'ouvragé
la collectivité a souhaité que ce
chantier soit un levier d'insertion pour
les bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
une des politiques que nous mettons en
oeuvre pour le compte du département et
sur instruction du département est en
fait de favoriser naturellement
l'aviation dans le cadre des marchés que
nous mettons en oeuvre notamment au
niveau des marchés de gros oeuvres
qu'ils soient de vrd de peintures et
autres il ya des heures réservées à
l'insertion donc par des clauses
spécifiques qui sont gérés à la fin avec
le département et la commune accueille
ce sera la possibilité de faire
bénéficier à des personnes souvent en
recherche d'emploi ou en recherche de
formation à une expérience pratique sur
le terrain de façon
à pouvoir récupérer un savoir faire et
être employables si le terme est
possible à pouvoir postuler pour un
emploi dans le même domaine demain